ان ترى النجوم في عز الظهر اقرب لك من ان
ترى دموع كيم جونج اون تتساقط وان سقطت
دموع الزعيم الكوري فيجب ان يخل الموقف
كله معمل التحليل السياسي هكذا يقول
الملايين حول العالم ولما لا فهو رجل واحد
اثار الجدل وحير مليارات البشر مجرد ان
تذكر اسمه ذلك كفيل ببث الرعب في نفوس
الملايين رسم لنفسه صوره الرجل الفولاذي
ودائما ما يرتبط اسمه بنهايه الكوكب الذي
نعيش عليه فاذا ذكرت الحروب النوويه ذكر ك
واذا ذكرت نهايه يه الحياه البشريه على
ظهر الكوكب يجب ان يذكر كيم لانه يمتلك
ذلك الزر الاحمر الذي ربطه بنبضات قلبه
وبمجرد
توقفها ستنطلق صواريخه النوويه من كل حدب
وصوب واذا ذكرت الحرب العالميه الثالثه
فستجد اسمه في تشكيله الفريق الاساسيه
وراس حربه ولكن هل تصدق ان ذلك الرجل الذي
نتحدث عنه هو نفسه من وقف معتذرا لشعبه
وباكيا امامهم على الهواء بل وظرف دموعه
في اكثر من مناسبه وكانه يقول كلنا كالقمر
له جانب مظلم ما هو الجانب المظلم في
شخصيه كيم جونغ اون ما هي اشهر المواقف
التي خانت كيم فيها عيناه لتظر الدموع
متجاهله اوامره وما هو الاعتذار الصادم
الذي قدمه لشعبه على الهواء دموع من اجل
الامهات رغم قوته وجبروته لم يستطع زعيم
كوريا الشماليه في لحظه نادره ان يحبس
دموعه من السقوط امام الاف الامهات فمنذ
ايام قليله واثناء الاجتماع الوطني
للامهات طالب كيم جونج اون الامهات بزياده
الانجاب من اجل مستقبل البلاد الامهات
تعلن استعدادهن لفعل اي شيء والتضحيه
بانفسهن من اجل مستقبل اطفالهن والنهوض
بالبلاد ليجه ش حين ه كيم بالبكاء ويظهر
امام عدسات الكاميرات وهو يمسح دموعه
بمنديله الخاص كان الموقف مهيبا ومؤثرا
لدرجه ان مئات الامهات الحاضرات للاجتماع
اجشن بالبكاء ايضا عندما راينا دموع زعيم
البلاد هامر على خديه وليس غريبا ان يتاثر
كام في مثل تلك اللحظات فمنذ بدايه حكمه
وهو يولي الامهات اهتماما خاصا حتى انه في
عام
2012 اعلن يوم الس 16س ع من نوفمبر من كل
عام ليكون عيدا خاصا بالامهات هذا بخلاف
عيد الام العالمي المعروف لذى الجميع
وماذا لو علمت انها ليست المره الوحيده
التي انهمرت فيها دموعك فمتى بكى ايضا رجل
كوريا الشماليه القوي اعتذار تاريخي وكان
زمن المعجزات لم ينتهي في كوريا الشماليه
ففي اكتوبر الماضي واثناء الاحتفال
بالذكرى
ال5 بتاسيس حزب العمال الكوري بالبلاد وقف
كين جونغ اون ليلقي خطابا بثى على الهواء
معلنا شعوره بالخجل واعتذاره عن الظروف
المعيشيه الصعبه التي يعيشها شعبه ولم
يتمالك كيم دموعه بعد ان خلع نظارته وهو
يقول اشعر بالخجل لانني لم استطع ان
اكافئهم بالشكل المناسب على ثقتكم الهائله
فمع اني توليت العمل الجبار للقائد العظيم
كيم ال سونج والقائد العظيم كين جونغ ال
وتحملت المسؤوليه الجسيمه لحكم البلاد الا
انني ما زلت افتقر للجهد والاخلاص لذلك لا
يزال مواطنون يع من وطاه الحياه اليوميه
ومصاعبها لا يا عزيزي ليست دعايه انتخابيه
او حتى تشويق اعلامي فبعد ان قال كيم تلك
الكلمات سقطت دموعه التي حاول اخفائها حتى
لا تلتقطها عدسات الكاميرات التي لا ترحم
كيم يودع معلمه يبدو انها شخصيه بالغه
التعقيد فرغم كل ما تسمعه عن غرائب كيم
جونغ اون وص لابه شخصيته الا انه لا ينسى
الجميل او هكذا يوضح الموقف ففي جنازه
قائد الجيش الشعبي الكوري هيون تول هاي
ظهر كيم وهو يبكي بينما كان يحمل نعشه
بنفسه وبعدها يهيل التراب على قبره بنفسه
ايضا ويعلن ان اسم تشول هاي سيخلد بجانب
اسمه في تاريخ البلاد وسط صدمه جموع
الحاضرين ولكن لماذا يفعل ذلك اليس هو نفس
الشخص الذي قام باعدام العديد من قاده
جيشه ومسؤولي حكومته بابشع الطرق لحظه يا
عزيزي فهون شول هاي يعتبر معلم كامل اول
والاشد اخلاصا له قبل وفاه والده كيم جونغ
اي عام
2011 وكان له دور رئيسي في اعداد كم ليكون
هو الزعيم القادم للبلاد ولم ينسى رجل كور
الشمالي القوي هذا الجميل وترجم اعترافه
به بان حمل نعشه واهال على قبره التراب
بنفسه وتخليد اسمه في تاريخ البلاد ودموعه
التي تعتبر ابعد لاعدائه من ان يطال نجوم
السماء تحليل الخبراء عندما يبكي من هم
مثل كيم جونغ فان دموعهم تدخل معمل
التحليل السياسي وهو ما حدث بعد وقائع
بكاء الزعيم الشمالي العديده امام الامهات
من شعبه وفي اعتذاره التاريخي وغيرها من
المناسبات النادره التي صدمت العالم بدموع
كيم فقد قال بعض المحللين ان بكاء كيم هي
محاوله من النظام الكوري الشمالي لتغيير
صورته امام العالم فالعالم اجمع اصبح ينظر
الى كوريا الشماليه على انها اخطر
دكتاتوريه موجوده على وجه الارض وزعيمها
الذي اشتهر بقوانينه الغريبه والمثيره
للجدل وطرق الاعدام البشعه التي يقوم بها
تجاه معارضيه وتسعى كوريا الشماليه لتغيير
تلك الصوره امام العالم خصوصا بعد الحرب
الشرسه التي يخوضها الغرب ضدها ونقصد هنا
البروباجاندا او الاعلام الغربي الذي صور
كوريا الشماليه وزعيمها بصوره سلبيه الى
ابعد الحدود وكانها اخطر دوله موجوده على
ظهر الكوكب وشعبها يعاني الامرين من
حكومته ويرى المحللون ان هذا التغيير في
توجه حكومه كوريا الشماليه وزعيمها قد بدا
في عام
2018 خصوصا بعد المقابلات العديده التي
جمعت بين كيم يونغ اون ورئيس الد اعداء
كوريا الشماليه ونقصد هنا دونالد ترامب
رئيس الولايات المتحده السابق حينها شعر
كيم لان هناك فرصه جيده لان تكسر كوريا
الشماليه حاله الانغلاق الشديده التي تعيش
فيها وتنفتح على العالم ولم لا فها هو
يجلس بجوار الرئيس الامريكي في بيونغ يانج
وكانه ما صديقين حميمين وكان عشرات
السنوات من العداء قد ذابت وانصهرت في
غضون ايام قليل لذا كان عليه ان يوجه
رساله للغرب يقول فيها انا لست بهذه
القصوى التي يظهرها اعلامكم انا شخص طبيعي
واتاثر كما يتاثر الاخرون وحتى عندما
امتلك السلاح النووي
[موسيقى]
ساتصور ترى ان انهمار دموع كيم خصوصا في
القضايا التي تخص النساء والاهتمام رهيب
الذي يعطيه للامهات من شعبه هو تمهيد
للشعب الكوري الشمالي بان زعيمهم القادم
سيكون امراه ونقصد هنا اخته كيميو جونغ
والتي تلقب باقوى امراه في كوريا الشماليه
او المراه الحديديه ونفوذها القوي الذي
تتمتع به والذي لم تحظى به اي امراه او
حتى اي شخص اخر في كوريا الشماليه من قبل
والسؤال لكم
هل حقا ظرف كيم دموعه من اجل الانفتاح على
الغرب ام هو تمهيد لشعبه حتى يقبل بان
تقودهم اخته ام ان هناك سبب اخر لم يصل
اليه المحللون اخبرونا في صندوق التعليقات